okay
all right hello everybody we get to do
another play the people today so I'm
Jonathan France I'll be playing against
you guys online here on leach s org so
if you guys do want you can challenge me
send me some five minute challenges
something like that
I appreciate everyone that's been here
waiting I guess in this view I don't get
to see how many people are actually
watching us but okay we got some
challenges here popping up so yeah
probably playing the people let me see
what's going on we're here looks like
everything seems to be working properly
let me know if you guys have any issues
seeing me hearing me that's sort of a
thing what's up new Devils
good to see you in the chat um we got a
three minute challenge here so I'm gonna
jump it over to the board and we'll give
this one a go against Victor gaucho so
let's see mmm
what do you do against Victor gaucho so
yeah it's been a while we had the
Karen's Cup we didn't get to do any
streaming during that so it's nice to be
back at it and starting tomorrow we have
the champions showdown so this actually
is one of the few streams we get to
sneak in here so in between events and
stuff we'll be sneaking some some stuff
in all right I'm gonna try this line
usually I pin but this line should be
good as well and then you always have
the hope that they go here and you play
here and you win immediately is this the
line where that happens no that must be
in the normal line I play we already
trade this Bishop for now this makes no
sense okay so I develop my stuff he's
gonna develop the stuff I want to
develop my stuff and there we go often
Roland yes I'm reading the chat here in
YouTube and twitch so yeah if you guys
got any questions
Alberto so you've challenged me
excellent I'll be looking at you it
looks like we're getting a couple now
looks like we're up to about three
challenges here so doing good LM are I
am LM much more prestigious so there's a
lot a lot fewer LMS out there in the
world than there are items so
power to the people good to see you me
panther you dunk hey from Zil what's up
all right so how do you play this line I
don't know but I seem to be moving
faster than my opponent all right some
trades yeah and then usually at some
point I'll Riemann over this Knight to
the d4 square that seems like my
strategical idea and I'll just castle
this way at some point I'll need to do
some sort of breakthrough stuff he wants
to trade more I'll play the same game I
don't feel like I should have too many
problems in this thing game will
reposition my knight to the d4 square
and hopefully I end up with a good night
Lee Chessmaster that's what we are
before I go to America I need to train
alright I hope we can help you Alberto
trying to see if there's a brilliant
trick after he goes here and I take if
there's any tricks against this I don't
see anything brilliant but it should be
okay for me um okay I'm gonna bring my
stuff in probably I can get going with
the plan like this all right if he's
gonna go here I guess I'll take this
which way is he gonna take back you took
this rook surprises me a little bit
excuse me I'm gonna bring my Brooks in
try to put pressure on this guy I also
now have another square for my knight if
I need to in the future
jump into the e5 square I stopped
playing mm they resigned too quick
well maybe Joe you're too good hey KB
Khan
well you're bad at chess let's play then
yes oh I feel like I'm doing all right
here against Victor
bringing her stuff random maneuvers or
here yeah we should be good I do like
the idea of moving this night kind of
quickly because then it always been
friends sent from going here due to this
bin hopefully you guys can see the
arrows and stuff as I draw them
okay so now see gearing up for this I
might very well be might very well be
can I go here let's go here just force
them back and then we'll make a decision
I might just
double Marik's
okay all right
yeah alright I'll take this way and then
I'll try to put my knight here just
making a joke I'm no good but I love
watching these streams
all right arrows invisible hey majority
attack I'm quite good yeah yeah okay
so he went through with this idea then I
can poke his rook then you can take this
thing I know let's take it back and I'm
just gonna take this and then should I
protect it protect it this way hard to
say it's hard to say Oh Joe slime what's
up Jonathan good to see play the people
back on Twitch there was a little low
after ladies night what happened yeah I
mean I'm hoping to get ladies night back
on because that was one of my favorite
streams I hope some of you guys were out
they were able to catch it that was a
good one so that'll be be coming back
it's just with all the the Karen's Cup
stuff that's been going on there hasn't
been - too much time for streams and
then unfortunately due to the fact that
we have another event coming right up
champion showdown streams will be down a
little bit but in our hearts we're
always here with our fans
I won't a pun against Victor I also got
to remember this is a three minute game
so awfully I don't lose some time so
we'll pick up we'll throw in a check for
fun or we'll take this fun we'll do
something we're gonna throw in a couple
checks hmm we'll go here for no reason
we'll go here and we'll win on time
I don't hate to be accused of trying to
be people over the board I just want to
thank you
check yay
all right thank you for the game Victor
Gaucho all right I see lots of new
challenges in here Oh including drunk
lifeguard okay I'm looking for five oh
but whatever if you guys are challenging
me to other stuff I have to play drunk
life garden because that's my brother
Isaac surance and and I know his
weakness it's the Scotch so that's what
we're doing
damn also his weakness outside of chess
who will win blues or maple leaves have
no idea about hockey I really don't have
any idea but I realized I was a hockey
reference end of my knowledge there
something about thanks for the red
potato in the grass oh good we get to
play this nice boring line all right
taking what the deep on there is unusual
usually it's able to be pond and then I
have the faintest idea of what I'm doing
but here I really have none so all right
I'm gonna try to put Mike Lee on f3
minam etc and could play some
pre-emptive move like h3 I'm just gonna
see if I can get away with it and I'm
just gonna put my bishop here pin him up
you know for the best I should get a
better pawn structure now if for example
he plays there I'll go here
I'll get a better pawn structure I'll
move my thing also somebody's talking on
here but I won't really attempt to to
listen okay you know some sort of random
night maneuvers and we'll pretend like
we're slightly better here he tacked my
phone does he read a chat yeah sometimes
I'm trying to read the chat to me that's
that's much more important than actually
winning or playing well I'm gonna go
here if he tries to scare mine anyway I
can actually take it um this queen is
actually bugging me a bit let's try to
treat I love a good trade karo is
streaming you should ask him to
challenge you yeah I saw Hikaru today he
was he was headed off to Whole Foods
which is where I was heading I saw him
he was leaving I was coming so I'm gonna
make any sense probably no so yes
her car was in town he'll be playing
tomorrow so I'm ready to move hopefully
he's not planning on that
there whatever whatever is happening
here
okay yeah all right let's trade I love
trades I can't resist
yeah
so don't really know what's happening
here but should be alright
now for the
bringing in the rooks face if you ever
takes this thing that I could play e5
check and then take this thing yeah
nobody's playing well he's starting
don't play me yeah it's a little bit
upsetting what can you do sometimes you
get outplayed alright so you can play
rook t2 I guess I'll go here yeah stop
playing so well Isaac what happened to
your series on openings
we need more yeah Jim McLaughlin has
really taken over he's doing a great job
what happened was I was I mean I have
some point I had a kid in real life and
then I also had a sort of a promotion
here I'm now the assistant manager at
the club and those things kind of
happened at the same time so you know
I'm working more and don't really have
as much time I liked doing the openings
class when there was a time where I
could you know make really good videos I
don't really want to at this point do it
if I'm not gonna like spend as much time
as I had been doing it on it before it's
the kind of thing I I really want to do
a good job if I end up doing it at all
so yeah for now it's it's Jim handling
the stuff my last year
yeah it's probably been a while since
Isaac beat me he's a strong chess player
and yeah looks like this one might go to
him
I'm in school right now should be
studying yeah who needs college I blame
high quality chess you must not be
talking about this dream but in general
yeah yeah chest is a bit distracting
what happened to the series of romantic
crime thriller set in various European
capitals or am I thinking of someone
else
yeah wasn't me but maybe alright so
what's happening here what's up why I'm
into my shoes it will be exciting
tournament so we got a big fan of Penta
Harry Krishna in the chat very exciting
all right I think with Suzy plays the
right move here I can resign
I guess Isaac didn't get the memo the
whole point is that our account goes up
and up all right
make some more random moves yeah it
feels like he can do one of these and
just break through there it is so could
be resigned the same could be resent I'm
alright well played well played Isaac
crushed me what was I reading today
something like 2000 something we'll see
even get it up a little bit not too much
just a little bit so we'll trying to
find the rated games looking for which
see if we can find a high rated player
get some of our points back I'm not
seeing anybody in particular so Edward
let's do this thing
I don't white in every game seems unfair
but who can complain you've been
promoted now you're the boss not quite
assistant manager which means at least
that there's some sort of manager which
is Ranchester and above him tony rich is
the executive director and above all joy
great general manager how isn't this
lost yeah it was lost time to resign
yeah yeah Isaac's too strong
everybody's too strong for me these days
yeah play the tol Bertos I didn't see
you I didn't see I was looking for you
oh I do see you
casual come on Elbert oh so that's why
that's why I didn't look make it rated
Alberto so I need the points back people
are gonna crush me I'm gonna need my
points back there he's gonna go here and
trade this thing hopefully I don't have
to mind too too much
lay with me all right just as my love
good to have you in the chat I wish I
could say chess was still my love but
now I just like talking to people in
chat playing bad chess yeah that's more
about
yeah we got some position here little
ward
all right thanks for the kind words
where man in my shoes I enjoy your
username you did enjoy my stream
I enjoy your username we're all having
fun also why are men in your shoes I'm
really I've been curious about this
lower-rated players need love that's
what we're here for you know if you want
naka all the good people you want Fabi
and Wesley that's tomorrow yeah if you
want to play some of they'll sit down
and play the people and I'm your man
comes big tech guy sneaking around so
also we should announce at this point if
you guys are here with us this time next
week the Dennis the room hopefully you
guys have all seen his trailer for blitz
bounty Dennis LaRue is now the guy that
does begin her breakdown and he's the
guy that is doing blitz bounty so
hopefully you guys will be able to watch
that next Tuesday at 8:45 p.m. Central
Time it's gonna be something amazing to
watch she's taking on Jacob Sanders so
we actually have a promotional video on
our YouTube channel hopefully you guys
have checked it out and hopefully at
some point during the stream if our tech
guy does whatever a crazy tech stuff
he's got to do he's getting run back to
some office make some thumbnail plug
some wires in hit a few buttons maybe we
can watch it on the stream before we
sign off today cuz it's gonna be
something amazing then you are strong
sorry he's got to finish his lunch first
he's a busy guy this guy's always
lunching and hopefully I'm not
blundering some sort of tectus or
something you are strong in theory
considering all your lectures
what would you say blocks may be the
wrong word you from achieving a higher
rating it's simply lack of dedication I
don't I don't put the time in that I
used to on chess I just you know play
around occasionally whatever on a stream
like this I'm not I'm not doing any
serious work on chess at the moment
although I will be having a serious
chess match coming up and I've also just
realized if I went to d2 he might have
this check for some sort of stuff going
on
and we'll reroute our night to here
maybe try to prevent bad stuff from
happening with any f3 stuff but yeah if
you don't study chess at all it's hard
to get better it's something that I
always want to do and hopefully there's
a time in my life when I have more time
dedicate because just as fun but only if
you can actually be serious about it do
I think somebody will be found guilty of
some charge no idea serious game
interesting okay um what are we doing
here yeah I feel like my Kings a little
weak I'm not exactly sure what he's
gonna do about it this bishops doing it
alright job those guys kind of tied down
looks like my pieces aren't great except
for this night um let's see what is he
doing he's going here to check this
thing pin do I need this bishop
trying to keep track of who's protecting
what yeah I obviously need to keep the
d2 square under control I have my night
my bishop doing that job right now I'm
just gonna play just a three minute game
so it is time to just pick it up a
little bit here we go play some random
moves time for the speed portion where
we don't do anything this is what the
people came here to watch so I'm having
difficulty with this mouse so losing on
time and a lot of this games seems like
a very serious possibility
it
ya know this is any good but we're
moving faster oh yay we did it okay
édouard got a little silly there at the
end could have could have easily gone
the other way he's saying a game I'll
click this good game button alright who
else we got Albert dos 5 plus 16 come on
that's ridiculous
5o would be good who's the highest guy
we got should play some high people
trying to get a few points back do we
lost
what is your handle and lead chest Oh
Danny can you spam the it's in the video
description so yeah this person is on
twitch askin for it
alright the London this is it here's how
you refute the London I learned this
from Magnus Carlsen himself he said
here's what you do you play this exact
move order and then if they go here
here's the trick Queen goes to c7 Knight
goes to d7 b6 Bishop e7 without castling
and then you try to play for the e5
break and that's the draw also don't ask
Magnus if he told me that because it's
not true but another grandmaster told me
it was true
Rosen says it's true all right we'll
take that as proof enough that this is
how you get an advantage as black which
is why the Linda's bust everyone should
give it up stop playing to London I'll
lose this game but that's beside the
point
okay so you guys got the links there
sent you a three-minute challenges rated
2007 all right we can look you up you
guys just got to remind me what it says
three minutes I'm gonna like forget I'm
playing it like five minute pace and
leaving chat and you know I like to goof
around a little bit
three minutes too serious I want to play
slow and bad haha so he plays for an
early e for himself all right quick
calculate this
all right so our our tech guy has run
hopefully he's gonna go and set up the
stuff so that we can show the
promotional trailer for blitz bounty on
the stream here
okay so I'm gonna be careful if he
throws this in he'll be threatening my
Queen moves away you'll have this check
so let me just castle which is also a
little bit scary a little bit scary he's
kind of he's done he knows what he's
doing a little bit all right so just
give me this guy cuz I'm scared and then
we'll get this guy out the way okay so I
can't castle at the moment he's got this
week fun now I can Castle just wanna get
my stuff out castle get my stuff out
then we'll be doing fine him castling is
actually surprising to me because I
thought you should keep this rook here
to have extra pressure for some sort of
attack no I don't know where his attack
will come from so this guy here this guy
here Brooks to DRC file okay should be
good for me now Benoni is my jam but
with good play white can draw without a
lot of trouble yeah yeah the modern
benoni is no baloney that's what I've
always said
London is a lazy opening teach them a
lesson
hey analysis chess he moved what do you
do okay let's go here try to trade also
I could've just taking this bishop table
here I'm not sure if I'm threatening to
take anything yet
interesting let's go here
sometimes nights can be tricky come on
night
mm-hmm okay I'll go back
come on Knights do a tricky Knight stuff
let's go
also maybe I should put my queen on e7
so that in this position I could play
rook to c7 but I have no problem making
lots of bad moves well Lynch oh good to
have you okay trade I love trading hey
he did Knight stuff to me that's unfair
that's really unfair okay how did I do
it the staff turn to me tournament yeah
win some lose some yeah first round
played a relatively underrated 800 he
played really well but I was able to win
that one and then I crushed Ben Simon
who you guys are probably aware of that
was a good game for me and then I
unfortunately lost to ryan Deering also
I just lost this game so yeah good game
David yeah I'm gonna lose all my games
today not in a good mood but yeah
staff tournament I guess bad was the
overall take dad was the overall take
alright here's someone good that we can
also lose to yeah the road back to 2000
see Caleb Denby he's always teaching the
road to 2000 I say if you're over 2,000
you can't get there so the only way for
me to get to 2,000 is to first lose
everything I have and then struggle my
way back up that's the plan Knights are
tricky yeah just I hate them
it's
Road to 1500 is your your goal near 1500
is not bet that's a very reasonable dog
I have one plan yeah but he kind of
stopped my planned
all right
sings detect
yeah everybody's playing so well - it's
like impossible for me to win a game
you can't win games everybody plays well
yeah everybody's just crushing me
I got no ideas here I got no ideas
yeah everyone's too good for me
feel like I'm just tremendously worse
and have no no plan at all
guess they should be playing for this so
far off just keeping ready to moves all
right Jim Grim Reaper's just at 1500 for
the first time today congratulations
reroute the night okay is that the
square you meant probably not doesn't
seem like a good square that's a random
square know where his night's going
either so we're both just making random
moves yeah I didn't really have a
problem playing this no here I come back
let me Baba the master oh he's
checkmating me
he's checkmating me come check me me
alright how bad could this structure be
alright we're men and my shoes flows
between 1275 and 1425 yeah it's not a
bad wrench
it's about the strength I'm playing
today so we're on the same level I
always gave up a few times but just keep
pushing
yeah
it's every game gotta be so bad
those dark squares yeah you know ya know
but that time you guys see the time
right that's that's how we're planning a
wedding
I guess he's trying to break through
like this is that his plan does that do
anything am I worried about that
probably not
trade I love a good trade let's trade
more one on time it's important that you
trade lots of stuff trade very exciting
he's gonna take a look upon me be ready
so this he's just gonna pretend like my
bishop strapped I mean it is I mean it
really is and I'm just gonna be playing
without that Bishop for a while it's
very sad
Bouck knows my idea put my Bishop there
just a pokum so I can gain that valuable
valuable second hey it's money yeah
we're live join join enjoy the stream
yeah yeah well if you do it's this
camera I believe if you feel compelled
to dance you got to dance when the
Spirit says dance I wish I had a light
squared bishop here
do we win on time yet poke yeah yeah
this is a good play this is very
instructive for everybody
week
that's all right I never had that guy
anyway
now Johnny come join us
don't you drone autographs hey
I do want a nice Bobby Fox autograph
check how are we doing do we want on
time yet
hmm we're both playing so well right
here
eek
yeah yeah I'll played me in the time
scramble
well done full fix yeah I think I was up
on time a bit well yeah yeah I'll played
me um we're on time all right
yeah I think I figured it out it's time
to really lower the stakes here then
find the lowest player on the list
hectic will give you a go
alright what are we doing here
you're not the lowest tactic in the
chatroom here is saying he's not the
lowest uh you're the lowest I could find
that it was challenging me at the moment
so that's why we're here battling it out
it's no offense deal I just really need
to get a win badly Bobby they're
crushing man it's been a tough day a
tough day at the office
that being said hectic you'll probably
crush me because I don't know what I'm
doing here I'm also sort of determined
to play things that I don't actually
know we're play what I play out here cuz
you know I know Caleb dembe's out there
watching me studying my every move April
12th America calendar that's when it all
goes down I take on the great Caleb
Denby do I play rated yeah only I try to
find only rated ones in theory I'm here
to make our rating go up but that's not
really what I'm doing today
yeah April tough big match against mr.
Caleb Dembe mark your calendar
can i play here there are many streamers
getting paid to play on chest comm sadly
I'm not one of them don't win a piece
ray it's about time I win a piece today
you're alive on YouTube as well correct
I'm funny and me are my moves my moves
are kind of funny
give me more night off videos yeah
I've been checking it out lately I've
been checking it out and yeah again it's
something I Phi if I'm gonna make videos
again or something I'd have to have
plenty of time I used to be I could I
had scheduled time to actually be here
at the club and and prep for all the
classes and stuff time is no longer
available to me for that purpose so for
now we'll let Jim who's retired and has
lots of time and he also puts a lot of
effort into his his videos we'll let him
handle that for a little bit it's fun
hanging I hope so I'm gonna take it
could easily be a trick but I don't see
it hope one day they will pay me to KP
Connor you're a big-time chess streamer
I check out your street
all right Thank You Aviva
all right he attacked me have fun I saw
it go taking this final check I didn't
see it huge chest streamer yeah look at
the event on Chester Commons hosting
right now some very well-known gyms oh
yeah someone said naka was was streaming
sounds believable
that's a queen yay we want a game today
I'm very excited thank you hectic
actually yeah you played really well so
you dropped dropped a piece there your
position was fine until then we crank it
back up a little bit whoo I'm weaker
than you well that sounds good please
play weaker than me all right we're
going d4 time to get serious how to play
against me you go to Lee chess org and
you challenge st. Louis chess club so
there was a link at one point I think
our tech guys gone so we can't spam the
link
Kibby [ __ ] big-time jokester
big-time chess newbie nothing wrong with
that
hey wait Aang Kings Indian what to do
other stuff maybe
decorating stuck at 1,400 nothing wrong
with that I like the Petrosian variation
here I feel like this is a good way for
wait to play don't know this move of
course so here we are my general idea in
here is not to Castle right away but to
sort of yeah play moves that prevent
checkmate probably make any sense in
this exact position I don't know but
we're gonna do this it's a basic plan in
a different position protests League
it's big online chess event is that
what's going on right now I guess that's
true I think the archbishop's play
tonight like super ultra mega late all
right now I was just kidding checkmate
here I come
rawr um s4 Shh
I suppose I pronounce your name good to
see you oh [ __ ]
do you see when I say yeah we see it
just like checkmate him yet
okay yes I appreciate you guys watching
me if they also you could be watching
the protest League it's kind of cool
that you guys are are hanging out with
us they play here for some reason I
don't know why we don't see the link now
Oh Danny now that you're back can you
put the link in again everyone's asking
about it so hopefully some other people
can challenge us who's Richard I don't
know what's his what's his name what's
what's his name
Oh Richard pointer can i order some
supplies through the chat yeah yeah some
people might not know it I'm the guy
that orders the supplies around here so
yeah just tell me what you need Richard
what do you need more Perrier
all right what's happening here
what do I like most teaching playing
watching watching is the easiest I do it
I do enjoy teaching a bit playing yeah
as you can tell not my strong suit
what is f5
he is just weakening his King yeah it's
typical in these lines but you know
alright now for some smart move here
here comes a smart move attack something
once
maybe I went upon that's exciting oh how
clever I am yeah it seems typical he's
gonna put a night here at some point
[Music]
he's gonna play c5 probably I should be
figuring out why do we play chess when
there's just hours and hours the mental
toilet rating is a board game I don't
know I've been playing chess for years
and just hit my floor in classical we'll
try to break through to I can here comer
anything I'm getting like worse it like
here test
I just can't improve at all why should I
even go on that's Mike's probably
scheduled to be here we got protests
language that means Mike should be here
yeah what's that challenge a small child
to describe attack given the chance to
win some money
and then crush his dreams there's like
one I might be playing in loud Danny
what are you doing this do you have the
Blitz bountyhead playing I guess
everyone can hear it someone in the
office has a live mic is that something
we can play after this game well I mean
they'll hear oh my gosh what's happening
there's no time
nobody warned me about time No alright
so we lost another game see I can't do
three minute games silly
yes is all silly mmm alright but take
your time I'm weaker than you alright
take a 30-second break from chats what
does that move what's happening
no no my queen this is good stuff
this is where it really heats up yeah
yeah yeah yeah um
good to see you streaming again also
capable of is doing a great job with the
lectures for sure he's one of the best
and he's the guy I'm Anna I'm gonna face
in a match and hopefully we're not
playing three minutes because I'll just
get crushed anyway well done I'm weaker
than you alright can I win one game
today just one
speaking of Mike comer will play Mike
and Mike all right I'm black for like
the first time today
hey you crushed me you know Isaac Sean
since entering the building
fresh off of his scintillating victory
okay are you here to help set up the
thing got a move I normally make but
let's give it a go all right thanks for
the game yeah yeah I played too slow and
I lost what's happening here is this
quite bad for me
Oh oops there maybe this is bad for me
but I didn't happen
I was waiting for a five-minute this is
three minutes to play fast and look at
the chat list doesn't sound like me for
me it's about 90% about the chat very
little about the chess as I'm trying to
demonstrate on every single move
perfect I don't want to talk anymore
[Music]
[Music]
all right they can hear me again no
that's not a good sign but yeah
everybody is eagerly awaiting to hear
the the Blitz bounty promotional video
me I'm just eager for all these Russians
to stop if my comers in a promotional
video it must be good and you guys can
go watch it too on on our YouTube
channel right now if you guys are need
to see it before anybody else every move
I play is dumb
no video oh alright you guys will have
to go to youtube if you guys want to
watch it sometimes we are awkwardly
listening to those sounds yeah that's
enough to get you hype it up before it
though hopefully what's happening here
I'm losing okay so everything's normal
everything's normal here
what is the video called great question
if you find there it'll stay like Blitz
bounty and then it says somewhere that
it's a it's a promotional video couldn't
tell you the exact name go to our
YouTube channel you'll find it it's one
of the last videos that went out she's
also sad I lost this game yet I know
what the people want they want I would
like a link in chat but you guys censor
links yeah maybe maybe Danny or Isaac
can toss the link to the promotional
video in the chat
eeeek
what's his biggest threat
don't understand why he's turned into
the e-file to you yeah I know this game
makes sense
all right there is the link presumably
what's happening I can trade Queens when
on time I'm like barely losing now I
should be barely losing
it'll check me remove up no I'll check
me with the night and take my Brooke no
all right we might finally get a win
today
for the first time Mike and bike thank
you for the game yeah you were crushing
me but then I managed to pull through in
the very end all right who else is good
mmm
not seeing a lot not seeing a lot did I
already play full fix I think so
didn't you meet me on time yeah we've
played before call me Bob I'm a big-time
time on/off player I have to remind
myself that every time I play up this
line don't really know what I'm doing
so I'll develop my pieces in Kessel why
the low rating this is a shared account
and they let me play on it I guess
that's why it's so low yeah if I lose
all my games the rating goes down
buxom in check me okay
probably shouldn't mind trading the
LightSquared bishop s-- my guys not
really any good and I guess some few
retreats I could consider putting my
bishop here i'm the other night here
play me this a car or a French I believe
we transpose to ac3 Sicilian is what we
got going on here no take me all right
yeah yeah let's put this guy here this
guy here he must whoops leak this guy
wants to go here and take my bishop
I guess so be it
this is a mess feels normal to me
all right do this do that this was a
three minute game - all right I guess
it's 3 min a day but I'll never realize
trade
I love trades
mm seems a little weak but there's not a
lot of pressure against them
seems a little weak no pressure against
them yet and have some ideas doing this
in this also good go here turn the
bishop in upon lots of exciting options
I can go here turning upon and upon I
get checkmated don't check me me please
come on call me Bob
all right
what are we doing here over here and
I'll go here I'm assuming he wants to
take this thing dad say all right he
could take care if he wants I'll take
care pretend to have compensation or
what's right okay now for they're
pretending that this thing is weak in my
bishops better yeah pretend we can win a
time pushing the aah pawns there's
always a nice idea yeah don't we go take
this more pressure here if she pushes I
take you yeah this feels good for you
well double up already
you make sure you always walk in front
of the camera to nut okay I'm seeing
this from Chile oh I need more yeah
thanks sir this is uh maybe if I just
have one more Cup then I'll really well
really start crushing it today I'm just
one couple way I'm always at least one
cup away from playing a lot better than
I do but I want a pun yes someone two
buns yes trade come on you know you want
to trade yes I won three buns
Oh pond you can do it make it go come on
you can do it okay I should be able to
win this one
very excited all right yeah how many
bombs typing something Chris dole X all
right I don't know what you mean call me
Bob
we got a notification hey tutorials on
YouTube thank you very much um unsound
SEC then mate
three two that gives me a little bit
more time we'll give this guy a go see
four take it you're a hero
are they still doing anything out there
is there like a meeting someone in all
right mmm all right here we'll play some
sort of random just just seems best
all right but I'm waiting for his
unsound sack it's coming go yeah this
seems like a position Rebecca might be
able to generate some sort of attacking
chances I'm guessing by the username
that he is one of those guys that tries
to checkmate you wait he went back what
was that about
I'm gonna go here so I can put my bishop
here and analysis ready moves
Roxy bind tight position yeah I'm trying
to set one up well go here maybe I'll
have an unsound sack then we'll need to
checkmate
no that was his point it's just an idea
yet probably not
let's do it
what did I calculate after here don't
worry about a lot of good stuff I
calculated many people play this opening
his weight I guess are you playing three
mini-games only not on purpose I'm
getting tricked by you guys I really
want to just play five minutes
but everybody challenges me to three
minutes I've mostly been doing it based
off of who I'm trying to play yes is
this a smart move come on I hope I can
play one smart move doesn't even have to
be good just let me like take your
Bishop and then claim that I'm smart
who's out there does he want to stream
with me it doesn't strike me as a
streamer but you never know he's
grumbling about something I guess I can
still do here my position should be
alright he's made a lot of pawn moves
not sure where his king is gonna live
forever I guess he's just gonna chill
there I suppose you can castle this way
yeah intend on taking this if he does
nothing I think that should be good for
me he takes back with tonight I'm gonna
bring my bishop to this diagonal even if
you like protects it I'm gonna have some
threats at some point here at some point
I don't think I'll be that tough to beat
not playing chess yet today oh guy in
box with the five minute challenge you
might be just the guy I've been waiting
to play cuz poor me I can't win a single
game today well in five minutes you know
a lot of people are waiting for a
beginning alright we'll get to the
5-minute games we will get to the
five-minute portion of this show also
then I get to play so much less chess if
it's 5 minutes that's what I aim for
they said it's a 90-minute show I just
play 5 minutes that should only be like
8 games or something so what am i doing
I'm gonna play like 10 to 12 games today
this is awful
I might be winning here though we'll see
what mr. unsound sack there mate comes
up with I suppose you should give
serious consideration to this move after
which I can win a piece by taking his
queen
and I suppose if I take here and he goes
here they go here don't know you don't
confuse me so he should do it
you will try come on son ii think it
made it drinking coffee and playing
chess yeah they go well together I can't
really play chess without coffee I can
barely get through my day without coffee
if you know any major coffee
corporations they're looking for a
sponsorship deal with a somehow slightly
above average chess player I'm the guy
yeah Archbishop's are playing tonight at
some point we'll probably start doing
commentary he spent so long I'm not I'm
really gonna think here what kind of
coffee am i drinking it's it's Starbucks
but we we made it ourselves here in the
club it's the Pikes Place just normal
filtered yep filtered our instant it is
filtered I'm sound SEC but there will be
no checkmate
oh no wait this has an increment dang it
I was about to start giving up all my
pieces but now I've just realized
there's some sort of increment here so
that makes no sense but an unsound sack
was necessary in this game someone had
to do it hey stop it
trait my favorite
all right how people are watching us
from Slovakia welcome Europe come on no
there's an increment I just want to flag
you maybe I shouldn't have given away a
piece for no reason
I said cheers doll
hey we wanted time yes all right
what was your five minutes all right
let's do this this guy add row' you've
been waiting for quite some time before
if your account is 42 I must be on
twitch yeah we're probably not doing
well in the views if you could be
watching a pro chess League well that's
cool it's cool for everybody that's here
all right what's the point of this like
d4 is bad or something I don't know I
don't know the deep intricacies of this
move so I'm gonna keep developing my
pieces and castle love from Scotland
what's up Robert watching in Scotland
I've been to Scotland it was a fantastic
place
we had a little tour tour guide was
wearing you know guilt and everything
obviously not really sure if that's a
real thing that you guys are doing all
the time I think they're just humoring
people going on tours Diane bucks also
from Scotland do I play rapids I'm
trying to play like five-minute games on
this stream but you know maybe next time
we'll just play one long game I'd only
have to lose one game this is this seems
like the most logical thing they can
think of it's 90 minutes play game 45
play one game call it a day all right
I found a square I hope you doesn't stop
me it'll be out of look yeah
all right so somehow I should probably
be taking control over this square you
know some sort of deep something that
that shears doll is a term of endearment
hey from Romania what's up mister
Cyprian take my life you'll never take
my haggis
I don't know this guy's up to this
bishop so just gonna get rid of just
gonna get rid of him and then she's
gonna get rid of them and put this guy
here and then pretend all I need is this
square and we'll all come together for
me brilliantly so let's go
yeah you were kilts daily of course yeah
Mel Gibson is American true what was
going on is going on I would do what
this guy no idea
hey you're better than me what do I do
here yeah that one that one that's the
move
sweet I was I was hoping that was a
great move I suspect it's not but here
we are
is this the account of the Chess Club or
yours this is the Chess Club account
yep st. Louis Chess Club is our name so
yeah you'll see quite a lot of other
streamers playing from this account why
am I taking this I don't know stump I
want to play c3 so just taking that
going here
hoping you know for stupid stuff like
there and fork but probably I can have
it all right my only idea here was to
play c3 at some point maybe d4 at some
point maybe this guy comes to life
somewhere mostly one time maybe I should
have stuck to the faster stuff I were
chances to win on time when's my next
skateboarding video no somebody named
cerned
in the chat he makes lots of
skateboarding videos that sounds cool
what happened here
I'm just Queen sneaked in what's going
on what is there a queen lurking around
in my my little house here this is my
side of the board what's going on and go
away
all right new idea attack something once
go back here take something once see I'm
doing great today
any advice for 15 to 1600s wanting to be
more like 19 to 2000 rated not sure I've
demonstrated that being 19 to 2000 rated
is that great I'm trying to be more
relatable by playing so bad do you guys
say how is this guy rated whatever he's
rated but yeah a lot of it is just comes
down to to study do more tactics do rate
some strategy books read some openings
hey look now I can attack this thing
again
look at that I'm finding all the single
attacks finding all this singing f4
Shirley wins who's the next Jim to
stream with you
Pepa Cuenca is here now but
unfortunately on Thursday will be having
the champions showdown so he won't be
streaming I was hoping he came by today
Isaac or Danny can maybe ask if he's
here ask somebody at the club if he's
here
if he's here he can come join me you can
do it right now go I was considering
going here because if he takes this then
maybe this thing is a little bit weaker
what is happening
yes hey from Canada good to see you Jeff
you sent me a challenge looking forward
to getting crushed yeah
today it feels like anybody can crush me
what books do I recommend I've said it
many times the book that I I believe has
helped me the most is mastering chess
strategy by Johann Halston yeah it's
just fantastic
strategy book 2 helped me out quite a
lot I feel like I read it at just the
right time for it to be quite useful and
meaningful to me so and yeah that's a
good one
I don't know open this up
Wow it's just aggressive stuff
aggressive stuff I don't know
never saw that one coming
Zach the exchange how do I do that is
there an exchange here to be sacked just
take this thing can't be what you guys
mean right yes mister singing saw this
all the way add row also this wins in
exchange this appears to win at rook
that's protected but maybe he doesn't
realize wait a minute so if I do nothing
was he doing does he have some plan yeah
okay he didn't know that was predicted
what was your rating when you read it I
was like 1,300 when I read the the
Helston book mastering chess strategy
you know some other books like opening
strategy and game strategy that's sort
of a thing
thank you add row' but yeah it just
helped me and then I went to like 1800
just read one book I took it very
seriously I did it like when they say
spend 15 minutes here or whatever then I
would do that see I see some 1800s is
that the highest I got here all right
Ming gloom all we got time for just a
couple more it appears that I will not
finish before I started yeah we got to
mm then we lost all of our rating it
whatever French now we've already played
a French today maybe I should have
picked some different hey come in here
hey it's about time yeah you here for
work yeah you're here but now that and
Friends finally makes sense and you're
not even okay what's what's up okay
perfect I don't need you you don't need
me no I need you for emotional support
I'm getting crushed today okay this is
not going well today
do people Castle this way yeah
all right I intend I'm just playing d5
here so I will yeah all part of the plan
free stuff um my intention was to take
here all right so yeah oh yeah that's
the guy that's the guy I need to crush
them I'm gonna take this
Brookes in hope this means he can't
castle that way hope his King a stuck
here
hope cracks under the pressure hey
fruity pigs super aggressive French yeah
this is aggressive stuff used to know a
little bit about what to do here but not
an ID like this interesting so bad you
want to trade
I do love trades yeah that's my favorite
I love trading I'm sucker for a good
trade and Queen takes rook here seems
like an easy move to make threatening
this is Queen the Quebec he's gonna
threaten checkmate but I'm gonna get
there first yeah go me very exciting
game
thank you make them out who else is good
casual oh don't be good and casual all
right this is pretty good for us makka
pakka let's get it on do you find it
strange thousands of strangers watching
you constantly I don't know kind of used
to it opinion on the grub it's bad
that's my opinion
was what's happening here that was when
I can take and do this and this is
supposed to be good for me but I always
mess it up they play Queen b6 I take
this thing winning upon somehow they get
enough compensation and then they beat
me that's how this thing works work him
good to see ya what has been seen cannot
be unseen where's Isaac I know we need
to get the better sure on sin here I
know you guys went into the sound booth
don't know what he's up to
pun
all right now horrible stuff will happen
to my clean somehow trying to determine
how I'm gonna lose this game trying to
determine if he goes here if I can take
this or go here but I'm not gonna
calculate just simply refuse
eat strawberry rose
play the Halloween game bet yeah
Grandmaster told me that was one of his
favorite videos as well so you have
people in twitch and on Li chests are
both talking about the Halloween game
but at the same time yeah that's
definitely one of the more fun ones that
we've ever done and the goal was always
to do a Frankenstein Dracula one cuz I
already have the counts costume just
need a Frankenstein head and then we'd
be able to talk about the Frankenstein
Dracula it all made sense to me but
there just wasn't time hey I'm up a pond
that's very exciting
Aaron
anyway do I prefer d4 or eat for better
mostly I play you for I mean alright
sorry I mostly I play d4 when I'm you
know being serious
my duplayee for though I've sort of I go
back and forth probably every six to
twelve months I change and those are
when I'm playing serious just those are
the only two moves that I play and yeah
just go back and forth now I'm about
ready to do this to try to get a bishop
don't member chanson the Helloween
gambit just count fun heading sharra
yeah yeah that guy's good he's a lot
better at chess than me at the counts -
B - Jim a GM with a three
so grab should be okay yeah obviously at
some level you can just blame everyone
and I'm hoping he escapes this thing
this way and then this wall I'll get to
take him give me that
that was your point interesting are you
interesting alright yeah well there's
more puns
anyway stuff the pun that's exciting all
right now for some random moves
don't watch a lot of anime not big-time
anime guy well there's plenty of people
here at the club that are into that sort
of a thing G far
should be alright for me yeah I'm slowly
untangling I feel really good when I get
this guy to some useful square so then
I'll just be assuming I'm better because
of the more stuff that I gots but yeah I
haven't really gotten all my species out
yet
we'll see if I manage I play bullet
not very often yeah developer stuff
controls the square bring a rook to the
C file
okay what's he doing don't do anything
too slick Makka pakka
I suppose I do have this move if I want
it never the random moves g2 is a nice
little safety move just something from
my little random moves
um yeah I think I should consider we won
it here usually we can do that and you
can put your queen on h2 I didn't really
see a point staking it but you can give
it a try if you want to
meat isn't potential to draw with night
g3 right I don't know I didn't see it
but hey he's gonna do this all right are
you coming to join me come on I'm so
lonely doing what just talking to myself
there's nobody actually watching this
range and play their lunch all my pawns
yeah maybe this is more interesting for
him that I thought maybe maybe you don't
think so he's dead all right take your
time though Makka pakka
take your time very much' see all my
funds greenish to Queen takes h3 Queen
takes tree farm well let me help you
does that change so I guard h2 is what
you're saying
wow I really think you should have gone
for it I really think you should have
gone for it maybe I was pulling his ears
that was the point and I can't play here
because I don't know he's playing well
but too slowly so shut that up
no it's way harder to flag them as no
increment
and we get throw this move in just to
shock him up and check I know all the
tricks
aha yes this is true chess right here
this is what real chess looks like all
right let's do like two more we'll do
about two more games here Esperanto
maestro maybe this guy is aspiring to be
a master of the game of chess oh wait
this could just get me the 2000 right
somehow we got to make play something
different somehow oh you want to see the
wandering king yeah okay well bust it
out well bust it out so are you do you
think that that's a good opening dang it
I didn't somehow trap is clean dang it
it's really hoping I trapped his queen
my only trick all right oh you know he's
stopping my deep
checkmate attack okay oops I know
Danny's here so we have to make it a
little bit silly we're gonna get a
little bit silly I can feel it coming
you got a castle first and now here
comes the relentless checkmating attack
you gotta let him castle right I mean
explain would you do one of these
maneuvers see it's coming up dude look
it's and that many moves away I'm gonna
put pawn at can you give me a pun pawn
hat all right here we go okay it's
coming
say daddy six I'm threatening it now
well now it's stronger well now it seems
stronger you would just can't do it
can't do it just Canada can't be done
I know I'm not I'm not Danny but you
guys I just can't he's going he's going
long yeah but he can't he's protected
his stuff so now I can go long now's the
time how do I stop him from castling
tell me now what that's beyond my
ability of course yeah of course he can
take it back but well if he takes it
this way I will not take it back should
be five instantly like it was all
prepped schemas he's super boring
positional game I'm good for that he's
only been playing three or more it's got
like 20 challenges good luck yeah I
think we got this and we got one more
game
and hopefully the road to 2000 is is
drawing upon us if we can somehow beat
aspirant a maestro we should get there
if we can't now this was not a car oh
this was some sort of weird French
rubenstein sort of with a lot of deep
sacrificial ideas he left the game he
disconnected I don't believe it is that
true I wouldn't know
more time for games can I play one game
on the site can't play two games at once
yeah you never know who I'm gonna pick
lest there's still always a chance if
you guys still want to get in just
challenge st. Louis chess club I got one
more game in me got one more game but it
might be a silly one might be just like
this was silly but not really I can't
bring myself to play the move stand he
can just play instantly I love to see
the Italian game and wish you were here
at the beginning when there was the
possibility yeah please Simon that's the
thing right we can play Simon what
happens here yeah wait why am I not
winning here this guy thought for a long
time and then he did that is he thinking
here and I have to take but I don't have
to say great is that what he thought I'm
trying to understand why he blundered
that because he thought for a long time
and he's okay yes the road is over
the wrong long world is over so
challenge the best guy play
a guy in box oh he's in the middle I
can't like double primo go do you play
the Sicilian often yes I do I go back
and forth between Sicilian in the French
as my black repertoire here now and then
here this is the idea few things
wait c6 in that position if I ruined the
theory now okay well I'm kind of a
amateur wandering King player I'll let
you help me out here a little bit okay
that seems like kind of weakening in
positional anubius okay
yeah challenge the best guy ya know
Kings chaser we're it not for Danny you
were the one you were the highest rated
rate a challenger no it's Kings chaser
oh he doesn't crush the king he just
knows so and not to give too much
insight to Mr Sanders who will be
competing against Dennis LaRue in a
match
I almost played here which might be a
catastrophe but dance the rule was
giving serious consideration to playing
this opening does this lose it supposed
to like crush me right dead I lost games
over so it is I'm always losing dang it
I don't like this opening I guess what
do I do here just survive how do you
live a little bit longer
well I realized it late too just like I
mean like everybody else yeah guy in box
he could kick ass back down but if we
finish over 2000 we can't get back yeah
let's excuse him affect our stellar play
would be the only way anyone could
possibly be crushing us right now
well he's gonna play here I can't even
draw heroes my arrow drawing reading is
very low very low trade no but he was a
piece or two I went in exchange tell me
now take the Queen thanks my queen
I think his rook he takes my business
that weird material I can't even count
do you know long this week Smith hey way
but what's this devious maybe a guy in
boxing not the idea huh
guy and voxi felt last chances because
of me right now did this I'm doing well
yeah yeah well you haven't been watching
huh that's true I usually don't this is
an exchange it's actually a Brooke huh
just hear any was a whole rook I take it
he's doing it right now right well no
well there's somebody if I take it he
can detect my opinion and then when he
shut down my little block Oh huh he shut
down the block oh yeah I didn't know
that was checked though so that's why I
did not know that I understand so I
actually could have taken it and then if
I went there then I could dumb a little
cheeky thingy up you go
go away okay I think some point here
we'll be doing well at some point at
some point I'll start saying they were
doing well this one oh hi nice game DD
unpin so yeah we got our last game here
guy in box saying that he mucked up the
game during the game thank you for
spending valuable valuable seconds just
in case I can't beat you I appreciate
the extra time yeah you always drop
pieces and trust me I did not play so
very well this game so that trend might
continue I could very easily mess this
up
you've been watching me today right do
not resign shoot but this thing look at
my rooks are on different squares
different colors that my king that's the
trick that's how you don't get Knight
forged that's the trick to not getting
Knight worked no no see dark square dark
square oh I have a check I know
darts bird darts burns problem check
cause this check
you'll warn me though before like a
night force me right then you lose an
exchange beta Benja thank you
I am his favorite Louis to end the show
it's my favorite Louis yeah
the Makka pakka game you played was
quite an interesting analysis all right
guy in Bucks thank you for helping us
finish off getting us back to 2000 um
Danny just took off he's ready to shut
this stream down um so yeah thanks
everybody for tuning in and watching us
and I hope everybody has a good night
come back tomorrow and 1:00 p.m. Central
Time watch the champions showdown we'll
see you guys then